welcome back to the news joining us at
the desk he is Hollywood's go-to hair
stylist and our Drew crewer ladies and
gentlemen it's our dear friend Chris
Appleton
so very blessed to be at the desk well
you've been every single place on this
set I mean we just wanted to get
involved in this in these conversations
oh my God I feel like you guys get in I
love it well kick us up with our first
Europe story oh guys
you have no idea what's been going on in
the beauty industry nylon magazine
reports that 80s dues are back I see
drew a light up at least according to
Bella Hadid who has been recently
rocking an incredible 80s promper with a
side part which we all know is very
controversial on Tick Tock yeah a side
part is controversial and a side part
with a perm you have no idea how many
text messages I had today from Friends
saying is this back are we all going to
go
unfortunately I don't think it is
because it's the kind of look that you
do for a night and then most people want
to kind of feel a little bit more
relaxed the next day it's a it's a big
look to commit to however I'll bring you
on an era I'd say what is in is
definitely big kind of textured hair
think Julia Roberts in the 90s Pretty
Woman yeah trying to text you wild hair
and I'm also thinking of someone like
really close to me which has been a bit
of a trendsetter throughout the years
Miss Drew Barrymore from the 90s I do
believe you have a picture of you
rocking the look that is there she is
look at how hot is that by the way that
is I think a perm left over plus natural
way so good and a lot of bleach
um now I want to talk about you have
some hair news tied to an incredible
cause that you're closely involved with
um tell us everything about hair raising
hair raising is something I'm really
passionate about I think it was a beauty
industry it's really important to give
back and it's really important to give
back to those who need it and who needs
it more than children we're actually
supporting Boston's children's hospital
and it's the 14th year we've been doing
this where basically for one day we do a
cut-a-thon so we're cutting away and
creating awareness we're creating money
and fundraising for Boston's children's
hospital and giving back to those who
really need it this is the number one
Children's Hospital in the country and
we've actually raised over 1.4 million
dollars so far amazing 14 years
[Applause]
guess from The Amazing Boston's Children
Hospital please welcome the associate
chair in the department of Cardiology
and medical director of the cardio
neurodevelopment program Dr Jane
newberger hello Dr James
[Applause]
thank you may I ask oh oh first of all
you know when we were doing this story
in the brief I was so moved especially
you know sit down
um and I'm not trying to be bossy I'm
just like you sit down
um Dr Chain what does hair raising you
know what does the initiative mean to
you and the kids and their families
so we have children who appear at our
doorstep literally every day because
we're the court of last resort uh so for
us it means that it's the opportunity uh
to take care of them to innovate uh to
bring experts in every discipline around
that child and we work with the parents
because you know Drew you have children
yes there's nobody who knows their child
as well as a parent and so that
collaboration around an individual child
to give them Cutting Edge care is is
really what we're all about so thank you
so much
I didn't
not everyone knows this but I have two
children myself and you know as a parent
you know you would do anything for your
kids and I think being able to support
something like this was just so
important to me and everyone should be
aware of so thank you for the
opportunity
well Dr James
are donating five thousand dollars to
Boston's
and to dream dry I say thank you so much
and I would like to match you so that's
ten thousand dollars for Boston's
Children's Hospital
you know our way of saying thank you for
everything that you do there I'm gonna
get five thousand dollars as well let's
make it 15.
[Applause]
[Music]